Okay, in this episode, I actually wanted to walk you through my favorite entry
model.
Now, yes, I do have multiple different entry models.
It really just depends on what's happening in the market, what system is I'm
using.
But if I had to literally choose one entry model as my highest probability
entry model,
it would be this five minute manipulation model.
So first things first, as always, when we're trading this specific strategy, we
always
want to make sure that we are trading in alignment with the M15 direction.
Now we don't have to worry about what that direction is, whether it's this low
in here
or, you know, whatever any of it is, because the structure OS indicator does
all the heavy
lifting for us.
So it tells us that we're bearish to have a change of character here.
This is the swing low.
This is the swing high.
Therefore, it doesn't matter, we are already bearish.
And then the first step to the entry model is confirmation.
So whenever you are, whenever you are bearish M15 and you're looking to take a
trade, you
obviously want to become the M1, so the one minute timeframe to be looking for
the right
confirmation.
So this is the model.
This specific trade strategy is from one of the setups for my traditional SMC
system.
And this is the London sweep Asia, New York continuation.
So this happens when London session sweeps Asia and gives a change of character
.
So we sweep Asia or we give a break of structure or a change of character, but
some type of
structural continuation.
And then New York session comes back to mitigate the supply range from London
session.
So once we reach this level, it's about entry model, right, entry confirmation.
And so step one is always that one minute timeframe.
But what you can see right now is the M1 timeframe is bullish, right?
We're confirmed bullish.
So we aren't interested in looking for anything because we need to wait for the
M1 to realign.
And so you just simply have to sit on your hands and wait.
And then what we have here is this, right?
This is literally the most powerful entry model.
We have aggressive break of structure and change of character.
So now the M1 is bearish.
So now we're ready to take this trade.
And if we look at the five minute timeframe, you can see that it's such a clear
and obvious
five minute manipulation and expansion.
So in the five minute timeframe, we have this consolidation sweep of the
consolidation,
close back inside with a change of character.
Again, like I said, if there's any super high probability entry model, it's
going to be
this one, right?
Same simple logic, 15 minute bearish.
We're also aligned with the daily bias.
The daily bias is bearish as of right now, because if we go to the daily, we
can see
the previous days high sweeps above in here into this fair value gap, right,
and closes
back inside this range.
So we're expecting lower prices, for sure.
And then it's literally just a case of execute.
And so again, we're going to go back to the one minute timeframe to get the
actual entry
model.
And we're going to use the inverted fair value gap, right?
Inverted fair value gap is also probably my favorite when it comes to if there
's an inverted
fair value gap, that's why I would like to use.
So any one time there might be a fair value gap, there might be an order block,
an inverted
fair value gap, a breaker block, whatever the set might be for me inverted fair
value
gap is oftentimes my favorite.
And then it's literally just a case of placing your entry on the inverted fair
value gap.
Your stop loss, ideally at this M1 swing high.
And now we have a 15 minute and a one minute correlation, meaning that they are
both trading
in the same direction.
So we have a bearish, a 15 minute and a bearish one minute, plain and simple.
And then at the bare minimum, we just want to target this low down in here at
this region.
I personally for this specific model, I like to target one to five risk to
reward.
And then we can see how things play out.
You can see we get the confirmation, aggressive, heavily sell off.
We tag into the position and what do we do in the process in here, right?
We actually build the internal range liquidity that's sitting inside of this
region.
And then we sweep it into our entry.
Now what we have is a new breaker structure.
So now we have new lower low on the one minute timeframe.
And on the five minute timeframe again, you can see heavy manipulation,
aggressive, aggressive
sell off, right?
So what can you do in this situation?
Again, I'm looking at this is the same in trial, right?
We are a bearish and one and in this instance, I'm looking at the five minute
fair value
gap or if you see closely in here, there is a five minute invert fair value gap
.
This is just up here and that would technically be an opportunity to scale in.
It doesn't mean that you're obviously going to get tagged in.
It just means that that is a scale and opportunity.
You can see price tags in and we end up hitting both five bar on each position.
So the M five manipulation, invert fair value gap, some type of inversion be on
the one
minute that you can see in here or be on the five minute if it's available.
But it's the same thing over and over and over again.
It's the 15 minute bearish, the one minute reversal continuation scale in there
.
If there is actually any set up or any entry model that would be my favorite to
pair with
this indicator because at the end of the day, the indicator is doing the work
for you.
I already have the years of data on this system and in the indicator, I was
able to do like
we're bearish.
So sure, okay, we're sure, but we need to hit the point of interest and then we
wait
for the M one.
We're bearish.
So sure.
And so it's pretty much doing the heavy lifting for you.
And that's the ultimate benefit.